all right Caesars has the projected wind
totals the over-unders that you can
wager on I don't know how they're gonna
adjust these numbers if there ends up
being a shortened football season that's
a topic for a different day but based
upon a 16-game season there they are the
Chiefs and the Ravens topped the stack
with 12 that's the over-under the
stunner though Peter for the first time
in 17 years the New England Patriots are
below 9 there they are in a cluster of
teams with 8 and a half who would have
dreamed we'd see the Patriots and the
Browns
with the same over/under the Patriots
and the Bears with the same over-under
are you kidding me and how in the hell
are the Packers only at 8 and a half my
goodness I'll tell you what
I run not walk to the window to bet the
Packers over eight and a half there's
the rest of them all the way down to
Washington and the Jaguars at four and a
half
Cincinnati actually gets to five Peter
anything anything jump out at you when
you see those numbers the Packers eight
and a half now Mike I realize I just
said what you said is the dumbest thing
I've ever heard in my life is the
dumbest betting line I have in my life
are you kidding me eight and a half with
Aaron Rodgers healthy I mean that is
that is just rampant silliness and you
know could I have the Bengals at the
under yeah I got five come on
I mean decided cited Jo Burroughs gonna
be great jo burrows gonna be great but
he's not gonna instantly have that team
of a six win team yeah yeah
you know but but you know what is what's
what's cool about those numbers really
is that you know and I just saw him for
the first time I'm not a gambling guy
but when I saw those things Mike the one
thing I said was you know to me I am I'm
fascinated
that somebody sits somewhere in Las
Vegas and tries to figure out how to
make enough people bet the over and
enough people to bet the younger because
that's what gambling
is all about and the smartest thing that
they did there in my opinion I think
it's very smart is to put the Patriots
at eight and a half because honestly
right now today if you knew that the New
England Patriots were going to start
Jarrod Stidham and Brian Hoyer one of
those two or both
if they were gonna start the majority of
the games for that team this year I mean
seriously how many games do you think
they'd win do you think that Bill
Belichick just you know you know tosses
his head headphones on the sidelines and
and just because he's out there they
automatically win ten I mean that's
that's a little silly and so to me I am
fascinated by the Patriots number and
most of the rest of them are I mean the
Packers at eight and a half stop just
stop
can we put those up again because I saw
the Packers at eight and a half I saw
the Bears at eight and a half I want to
see where the Vikings are on this list
there there are at nine nine I'm not
mean the Vikings have had an exodus of
veteran talent they traded Stefon Diggs
Everson Griffin is gone and Lindvall
Joseph is gone they cut one of their
starting offensive linemen their
offensive line isn't all that great
Dalvin cook managed to be healthy most
of the year last year which was an
aberration relative to the rest of his
career
I don't know that of those four teams
I'm picking the Vikings is having the
highest win total I mean the Packers
were the two seed last year and they
were one drive inside the 5-yard line
between the Seahawks and the 49ers would
be the one seed it's it would be
different if the Packers had a down year
there's no reason to look at the Packers
and say boy they've really fallen apart
they were bad last year they're gonna be
worse this year I I don't get it and I
when I see something like that Peter my
thought is what this Vegas know that I
don't know because they have a hell of a
lot more incentive than I do when it
comes to figuring out what the right
numbers gonna be like you said they want
to set the betting equal on each end
there's no way
it's gonna be equal on each n that
number is going to go up and up because
people are gonna be taking the over mic
can we put that up again because I want
to see where the teams in the AFC East
are I want to see Buffalo in Miami okay
Buffalo's at nine show me where Miami is
let's go down expain in next page Miami
six Wow Miami's at six I take the over
on Miami right there I guarantee you
that I mean the Dolphins had a better
record than New England after Halloween
last year and that Jets are higher its
Jets are higher at six and a half how
about that that's that's not accurate
somebody you know I I don't know it's a
little bit silly but but look I think
we've all seen I'll never forget this
Mike last year I don't know I've done
this two or three years in a row as one
of the last columns I write before I go
on vacation I rank the NFL teams from 1
to 32 and the easiest thing of course
any year is to say hey let's look at the
standings of last year and project them
and have all those teams up at the top
well stupid me I add San Francisco at
number seven and I would wager that I've
never gotten more mail or email or
whatever saying you are an income Pope
putting the 49ers at seven and you know
all those people were right I put them
way too low and and my point is that in
the offseason we can look at things like
that and say me and that's idiotic
like I came out with something this week
I'm writing it for Monday in my column I
would not take a wide receiver in the
first round
I just wouldn't I understand how good CD
lamb is and all these guys but the
recent track record is that the far
better receivers over the last four
drafts far better not even close have
been taken in the second round and and
so and I've got some numbers to prove it
and everything
it's indisputable but but anyway the
initial reaction when I said something
about that on Twitter is go to bed old
man you know it's ridiculous that's dumb
so people don't like it when you say
something that is counter to what
they're pretty sure they believe like in
this week that CD Lam jerry judy and
henry rugs are all gonna get picked in
the top 20 and if you don't get one of
them all you've been left at the
starting gate and let me just amplify
your point there I think for Michael
Thomas who has become the best receiver
in the NFL broke by 10 receptions I
think the single-season receiving record
that had been held by Marvin Harrison
for years I think the fact that he went
the second round actually made him
better I feel like not it's a
combination of not caring around that
first round tag not having that ego
boost that comes from being a first
rounder and also having a chip on your
shoulder because you weren't a first
rounder I agree with you I want a guy
who's pissed off that he lasted on the
board as a [ __ ] in a year like this Eric
DeCosta the Ravens GM said last week
that you can find a starting receiver in
round five that's how many they are so I
get with you on that it's nice that we
agree on something after our knock-down
drag-out
Mike jr. I want to make one more point
about this because it's something that I
really believe in strongly okay to me
and I know we're far afield from your
original topic but I believe in what I
call trait receivers okay
like Michael Thomas he ran a four or
five five at the combine and everybody
said poof forget Michael Thomas we don't
want this guy he's too slow he's a
linebacker
well they didn't watch him win seventy
percent of the 5050 balls
they didn't watch how competitive he was
and how he is going to play just like
Jerry Rice for the rest of his life with
a chip on his shoulder and that is what
Sean Payton saw that is what Mickey
Loomis saw the New Orleans Saints saw
things that other people didn't and they
knew
because of the way their offense worked
an intermediate passing offense with
drew brees if you're really competitive
for the ball and if you're great after
the catch those are Michael Thomas's two
best traits that you're gonna fit in
just fine here and what he's done I'm
sure it surprises all of us but the the
Saints knew that he was gonna succeed
Deebo samuel trait receiver for the san
francisco 49ers
you know meek meek ole Hardman for
Kansas City the exact they can do a few
things that you really value in Kyle
Shanahan's offense in San Francisco and
in Andy Reid's office in Kent offense in
Kansas City
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports